non pensavo sarebbe stata così dura
ragazzi qualcuno mi aiuti ciao mariners
oggi voglio rovinarmi
in che senso voglio rovinarmi marina
spiegaci meglio allora io direi che ve
spiegarvelo meglio posso prendere
soltanto due cose da questo tavolo acqua
micellare e dischetti struccanti secondo
me adesso è di cerete a capire mi voglio
rovinare perché oggi voglio provare
insieme a voi tutte le viti in the
labbra una dopo l'altra
[Musica]
ebbene si ragazzi e ragazze ebbene sì è
arrivato il momento di fare questo video
che praticamente sono sicura che alla
fine del video e non mi sentirò più le
labbra a forzare struccarmi che adesso
un rossetto news quindi non è niente di
grave ma quando avrò la tinta labbra
tipo nera
parliamone se devo essere sincera se
devo essere sincera non sono tutte le
mie tinte labbra perché se no penso che
il video sarebbe durato dai 60 agli 80
minuti quindi ho selezionato insomma
quello è un po più particolari o quelle
chiuso di più alcuni non le ho mai messo
tra l'altro e siete pronti forse non
riesco neanche a provare tutte queste
perché ovviamente sono che qualcuno mi
aiuti qui davanti a me ho le mie
fantastiche di intel a bra che sono
della dx o della caf con gi oh di max o
di nabla partiamo subito
iniziamo con le tonalità un po meno
impegnative quindi coni miur
partiamo con il niger i libri o 4 che
sia questo il numero carina ma non avevo
mai messo questo dovete sapere che tanti
insomma me le mele danno da provare
quindi può essere che alcune non avviene
anche mai aperte voto da 1 a 10
fatemelo sapere nei commenti rimanendo
sul mood passiamo a ritmo nel di nabla
chiaramente ragazzino ne sto mettere
tutte precise sennò finiamo più
questa è una di quelle che metto più
spesso è veramente molto molto carino
ecco che inizia il patatrac nota mi sa
che dopo sto video la devo ricomprare la
quale genera grande micellare cioè la
fedele micellare domiciliare parlante da
solo milan cosa proviamo sempre di nabla
klose
simile alla prima no
un po più su rosino passiamo la tonalità
un po più decisa questo l'ho messo due
tre volte devo dire all'estate
forse i rari myers se lo ricorderanno
questa è top io adoro by rosso scuro
vabbè questo l'ho messa un pò veramente
la cavolo e sarà anche molto difficile
da togliere però il colore carinola
notiamo anche il rossore intorno a molto
fashion
dobbiamo barbie forse l'ho messo una
volta questo anche perché un colore
altamente impegnativo
[Musica]
già inizio per le labbra fucsia e non
per la tinta labbra che procediamo con
bell azzurro busco questo è un altro
molto molto molto sobrio forse non l'ho
mai messo questo l'avevo comprato così
pre sfizio chi sia non lo so tra gli
oggetti allora dopo l'azzurro buffo devo
dire che non ho più non mi sento più le
labbra ma proseguiamo perché io non mi
arrendo
adesso proverò la prima tinta labbra di
ma che ho provato ai tempi era insomma
la tonalità più più richiesta infatti
all'andata anche fuori produzione con
c'è ancora un po di azzurro
non fateci caso quanto è bella e mi ero
innamorata non sono tutto fucsia
a proposito di fucsia togliamo questo
dell'aics carino
adoro siamo solo a 129 dentro mi sembra
una vita che li prova o provi a questo
partito non ho mai provato forse nabla
analisi è tipo da grigio viola grigio un
po drammatico hulk iron man e il
problema ti rimane tra le pieghe a cura
dei denti a che passiamo un altro colore
molto sobrio un bel viola metallico
oscuro così un po un po alieno dai non è
malvagio vi piace o no tolgono
creare quasi metà della l'inps non so
come definirlo direi che è un bel rosso
acceso
lasciamo perdere come questo mi piace mi
non sono nostre esprimermi
io vi amo tantissimo ma non so se
riuscirò a provarne ancora molte perché
ho già le labbra tipo vanno a fuoco con
questo bellissimo di carbon di outlaw
[Musica]
top
torniamo alle dalle tonalità un po più
sobria a quest'altro quali cocktail di
double dee ce l'ho messo anche un sacco
questo anche molto carino un po pesca
vediamo questo mix libri o 2x l'idv in
questo nuovo paesaggio visto farfa
questa carino no
vediamolo adesso proviamo un marrone
scuro questo qua di hicks lcl 32
scurissimo questo colore topo ecco l'ho
definita così questa finta labbra la
rimetterò sicuramente spesso le labbra
non esistono pur non le sento più
non pensavo sarebbe stata così dura
ragazzi paghiamo gli ultimi colori
perché i ragazzi tutti questi li ha
trovati
stiamo scherzando allora questo qua di
nabla grace come la bimba di più carino
[Musica]
notare che ho ancora il grigio qui
voglio morire molto molto molto carino
questo lo metterò più spesso devo
continuare ragazza roth è stata una mia
idea cioè capito il problema ai dai che
ci siamo quasi
con gli ultimi allora torniamo a caso
fondi con questo a 15
devo fare metà e metà risparmiamo tempo
e le mie labbra non vanno a fuoco metà
questo messa sempre di kat von d beloved
carino questo duo mi piace non riesco
nuovo canone non riscosso reader mi
tirano le labbra tremenda
proseguiamo con un altro connubio questo
connubio e di nabla è un lato mettiamo
alter ego dall'altro mettiamo bad boy un
po tipo di duetto di giovanni rana una
parte un colore da una parte l'altro
quale preferite i due
fatemelo sapere nei commenti sia prima
auto le discussioni sotto questi
commenti perché insomma vi ho fatto 4
miliardi di domande dei ragazzi ormai
c'è un utile non va via in rosso quindi
così adesso pure sul naso questo di
nabla zen
non trovate che siano buffissimi a volte
i nomi di chiedere tinto labbra broadway
queste cose
beh sembra fossi messo in maniera
decente sono anche carino non provo
l'ultimo di kat von d del codice ai
ragazzi li ho fatti chiude la metà
quindi sono stata più brava
incredibile ma vero ragazzi ce l'abbiamo
fatta
li contiamo insieme 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 23
ragazzi 23
ho trovato 23 tinte labbra solo per voi
non ho più praticanti no 24 questo
governo fino al 24
non ho più insomma sensibilità per
quanto riguarda le mie labbra dischetti
ne abbiamo da collezionare appendere al
muro e spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto chiaramente ce ne sono tanti
altri tinte labbra nella mia make up
collection magari faccio anche la make
up collection si dirà e fatemi sapere
quale tinta labbra vi è piaciuta di più
o quali sono le tinte labbra che mi sono
piaciuti di più lasciandomi un
commentino qua sotto e come al solito se
non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate la
campanella che trovate vicino alla tassa
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i miei video e come
sempre seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social instagram facebook e musicali
vivendo un bacino con queste labbra
belle gonfie e doloranti e li voglio
tantissimo bene
[Musica]